heute war frühlingswetter in vielen
teilen deutschlands und die menschen
konnten so ein bisschen für ein paar
stunden corona vergessen hinter den
kulissen im politischen berlin
da tobt aber bereits der nächste streit
wie läuft es mit dem impfen weiter wie
geht es weiter mit den massen tests und
vor allem wird dieser lockdown noch mal
verlängert über diese fragen möchte ich
heute sprechen mit meinen gästen jana
schimke die stellvertretende vorsitzende
der mittelstands-union lars klingbeil
spd generalsekretär und christian
lindner fdp parteichef und direkt zu
beginn möchte ich ihnen einmal bilder
vom samstag aus sachsen anhalt zeigen
während so ist es geschrieben ist zu
unterlassen ist verwandte zu besuchen
hat die cdu in sachsen-anhalt diesen
parteitag abgehalten 880 menschen in
einem raum sie waren alle getestet muss
man sagen und dennoch wenn man diese
bilder sieht dann fragt man sich warum
sind dann eigentlich andere dinge beim
wenn wenn getestet wird nicht wirklich
darüber möchte ich direkt sprechen mit
lars klingbeil klingbeil was geht ihnen
durch den kopf wenn sie diese bilder vom
wochenende aus sachsen an als wäre also
erst mal sieht es natürlich sehr komisch
aus so viele menschen dicht an dicht auf
engem raum gebe auch zu sein nicht nach
150 abstand aus den man einhalten sollte
und gleichwohl muss ich natürlich sagen
für uns selbst parteien bestimmt hat
alle insgesamt vor der herausforderung
dass wir listen aufstellen müssen für
die bundestagswahl dass wir
entscheidungen treffen müssen wir haben
das parteiengesetz jetzt geändert sowas
kann auch digital stattfinden es gibt
doch ganz kreative form
ob das jetzt gesehen ein fußballstadion
auch mit ausreichend abstand und klar
ist auch 150 müssen eingehalten werden
masken sollten getragen werden es sollte
getestet werden wo das möglich ist die
dreht sich um die einen vorbericht und
es geht doch jetzt ziemlich um die 150
sondern vor allem um die symbolwirkung
die solche bilder haben wenn man als
bürger dieses landes angehalten
bei der letzten pressekonferenz wurde
das nochmal erwähnen dem beschluss steht
ist ist weiterhin zu unterlassen
verwandte zu besuchen ich solle mich
weiterhin komplett zurückhaltend und
dann sieht man diese bilder
da können sie mir doch nicht erklären
dass das sinnvoll ist als
regierungspartei so etwas abzuhalten
also nochmal wohnzimmer wir müssen
listenaufstellung für die bundestagswahl
damit demokratie funktionieren kann
dafür haben wir schwierigen festgelegt
im parlament das ganze geht auch digital
es geht auch draußen ich kann nicht
bewerten was die cdu in sachsen-anhalt
da gemacht hat aber klar ist doch wenn
solche veranstaltung stattfinden dann
mit abstand dann mit maske dann mit
tests herr lindner was haben sie gedacht
als sie diese veranstaltung gesehen
haben sie gehören als fdp-parteichef zu
denjenigen die immer gesagt haben wir
müssen konzepte schaffen wo man sich
dann treffen kann mit abstand mit
testung wenn sie jetzt sehen was die cdu
da gemacht hat am wochenende
glauben sie denn dann könnte man
eigentlich auch restaurants öffnen wenn
man sagt man hat sich vor getestet die
cdu zeigt es geht mit klugen hygiene
konzepten mit schutz konzepten ist
gesellschaftliches ist in dem fall
demokratisches leben möglich das darf
aber nicht nur beschränkt sein auf die
parteien die da hat lars klingbeil recht
jetzt wichtige politische entscheidungen
zu treffen haben
es ist zugleich ein versprechen für die
gesellschaft insgesamt
wenn wir jetzt die tests strategie
strategische ausweiten wenn wir die test
strategie implementieren so dass alle
günstig und umfänglich zugang zu schnell
und selbsttests haben in der maske
tragen wenn wir die digitalisierung des
gesundheitswesens weiter vorantreiben
wenn wir die wirklich gefährdeten
gruppen gezielt schützen
dann ist mehr gesellschaftliches leben
möglich ich glaube nicht dass die cdu in
sachsen anhalt einen fehler mit diesem
parteitag gemacht hat ich glaube dass
die krisenstrategie des cdu-geführten
kanzler amtes nicht mehr zur lage im
land nicht mehr zu den technischen
möglichkeiten und nicht mehr zu den
bedürfnissen der menschen passt
vor schimke was haben sich da ihre
parteikollegen in sachsen anhalt gedacht
der haseloff der ministerpräsident hat
all diese beschlüsse mitgetragen steht
auch dafür dass man sich eben nicht
versammeln sollen nicht treffen soll das
ich und braus privaten gründen was was
hat man sich dabei gedacht dass dann
gleichzeitig so ein parteitag
stattfinden kann
was glauben sie was denken die menschen
wenn die solche bilder sehen
naja das kann natürlich im ersten moment
etwas irritierend wirken aber wir haben
uns in der tat vor einigen monaten genau
über diese frage gedanken gemacht und
ich bin froh und dankbar darüber dass es
weiterhin möglich ist solche
nominierungs parteitage durchzuführen
gleichwohl sage ich auch ganz klar an
dieser stelle ist das natürlich ein
gutes beispiel auch für weitere für
weitere erleichterungen für weitere
öffnungen man sieht doch dass es geht
warum geht es nicht in anderen
gesellschaftlichen bereichen
herr klingbeil warum geht es nicht in
anderen gesellschaftlichen bereichen
macht das sinn zu sagen okay dann testen
wir eben vorher
und dann kann ein restaurant aufmachen
dann kann ein geschäft aufmachen
also ich meine in ihrem wahlkreis werden
sie doch auch wütende geschäftsinhaber
haben die sagen wir müssen jetzt endlich
wieder öffnen wer gar nicht das ist
jetzt langweilig wird wie wir uns alle
einig sind in der sache aber wir
brauchen jetzt eine klare perspektive
durch die politik die menschen sind nach
12 monaten kroner auch müde wir sind
dünnhäutig wir wollen jetzt das ist eine
klare perspektive gibt und das muss eine
mischung sein ja wir müssen beim impfen
vorankommen wir werden sehr viel über
das testen jetzt in den nächsten tagen
auch reden da sind wir viel zu spät dann
muss es jetzt klare entscheidungen geben
wir brauchen nach wie vor hygiene
konzepte aber hätten oder ein bajonett
erwarten wie man sich fragen ist den
meine frage nicht denn meine frage ist
ist das dann nicht eine
zweiklassengesellschaft wenn sie als
partei sagen okay so was muss möglich
sein die menschen können sich versammelt
und dann bei der nächsten mpk sagen sie
wieder na ja die zahlen sind jetzt so
gestiegen also lockern können wir nicht
und ihre verwandten dürfen sie auch
weiterhin nicht besuchen dass das klar
sein muss ist doch dass es jetzt regeln
braucht ab wann wieder aufgemacht wird
hat beim wieder kultur ab wann
gastronomie ab wann öffentliches leben
wieder stattfinden kann dafür brauchen
wir jetzt verbindliche regeln das ist
der auftrag der letzten
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz das
jetzt erfolgen und da sind wir uns
glaube ich würde ich jetzt mal sagen je
nach den eingang statements einig in
dieser runde der länder letzte frage zu
den bildern da aus sachsen-anhalt
glauben sie dass das hättest du eine art
signalwirkung haben kann auch für andere
bereiche werden sie daher an haseloff
und andere daran erinnern dass das ja in
sachsen-anhalt eben möglich war
naja die fdp hat im letzten jahr bereits
ein präsenz parteitag durchgeführt mit
sehr strengen hygiene konzepten aber es
hat danach nicht eine einzige infektion
gegeben
das zeigt mir es ist schon jetzt mehr
möglich übrigens haben wir ja in
deutschland auch viele städte und
landkreise die schon deutlich unterhalb
der 50 bzw der 35 neuinfektionen pro
100000 einwohner und woche sind da wäre
schon jetzt und müsste auch schon jetzt
sehr viel mehr erlaubt werden als es
eigentlich passiert das kanzleramt hat
sich festgelegt auf einen bundesweiten
pauschalen und flächendeckenden lockdown
ich halte das für falsch und auch nicht
für verhältnismäßig insbesondere dann
wenn ab dem ersten märz jetzt die
friseure öffnen können was richtig ist
werden viele andere sich fragen die
ebenfalls im handel in der gastronomie
im fitnessstudio im kosmetiksalon
hygiene konzepte garantieren können
warum sie nicht öffnen dürfen
und deshalb ist jetzt dringend ein
politischer richtungswechsel
erforderlich er ist überfällig und er
ist möglich corona ist eine gefährliche
erkrankung aber nach mehr als einem jahr
müssen wir auch als hoch entwickelte
industrienationen mit dieser
herausforderung anders umgehen als nur
mit dem prinzip wir bleiben zu hause
ich möchte ihn einmal zeigen und sie
haben es wahrscheinlich selbst gesehen
wie es heute und gestern in den städten
aussah
da gab es tolle bilder man hat sich so
ein bisschen fast im frühling gefühlt
hier sehen wir die isa voll in münchen
am wochenende die menschen haben es
genossen und für einen moment
wahrscheinlich corona vergessen auch in
berlin war viel los auf den straßen
er klingt wenn sie die bilder
sie waren vielleicht auch draußen am
wochenende wenn das wetter draußen
besser wird dann scheint den menschen
corona langsam egal zu werden oder
ich glaube nicht dass wir das den
menschen krone egal ist und wir müssen
doch auch festhalten
seit zwölf monaten machen 99 prozent der
menschen in diesem land ganz viel mit
was die politik sagt und für die politik
darum bittet also ich glaube nicht dass
es eine egal haltung ist aber natürlich
freut man sich doch nach monaten oder
nacht nach tagen jetzt auch dies kalt
war die man zuhause festigen dass jetzt
die sonnenstrahlen da sind nun alle
rausgehen das halte ich für absolut
verständlich und trotzdem konnte ich
beobachten da wo ich draußen war man
hält sich auch an abständen man passt
aufeinander auf also das sind keine
sachen die gegensätzlich sind das leute
draußen sind und dass man sich weiter an
die regeln hält aber es geht doch um
politische verantwortung und die liegt
jetzt drin dass wir klar sagen ab ins
ident von 35 ab entwicklungen die
positiv sind kann man wieder aufmachen
kann man kulturelles leben öffentliches
leben zurück legen wir werden uns die
institute anschauen und wenn wir uns die
inzidenz und anschauen dann werden wir
die 35 ja eigentlich nie erreichen und
wir wissen ja alle dass diese instanzen
eigentlich ein künstlicher wert sind wo
es sozusagen um die vermeintliche
überlastung geht und die
zurückverfolgung eben von den
gesundheitsämtern warum krallen sie sich
da an den 35 fest wenn sie jetzt schon
sehen dass die werte doch massiv wieder
steigen werden wahrscheinlich gerade
wenn dann menschen eben unterwegs sind
draußen sind wir sehen ja auch schon den
letzten tagen die zahl geht leicht
wieder nach oben wenn sie jetzt wieder
mit der 35 kommen dann nehmen sie den
menschen doch je weniger hoffnung also
erstmal sind das ja die zahlen die leute
infektionsschutzgesetz das beschlossen
wurde vom parlament das auch noch mal
bestätigt wurde in regierung wo die
union mit dabei ist wo die fdp mit dabei
ist es ist ja das was politisch
entschieden ist und es geht ja um mehr
als die instanzen es geht doch um die
frage in bewegung der intensivbetten es
geht für mich um die frage auch wie
stark ist eigentlich die impfquote in
diesem land es geht um die frage testen
wo wir ja ich vermute er kostet kann
damit seine quote ist schlecht wie auch
in den in den letzten wochen will sehen
die bilder aus israel wo die menschen
bei einer bar sitzen und dann geimpft
werden da gibt es noch ein bier und
schott dazu und
hier sehen wir das noch einmal wie das
in israel funktioniert und wie zufrieden
die menschen sind und hier wird
angestoßen mit einem bier auf den bayern
tech impfstoff der da verimpft wurde und
israel wird jetzt wieder alles auf
machen vor schimke wenn sie diese bilder
da sehen wie glücklich die menschen sind
dass das funktioniert bei ihnen wie
wütend sind sie dass ihr
gesundheitsminister dass ihre kanzlerin
dass die eu kommissionspräsident hinter
so versagt haben
35 sind schon ein schlag ins gesicht
gewesen
für viele unternehmerinnen unternehmer
für die menschen hier vor ort man sehnt
sich wirklich sehr sehr stark danach
wieder am leben in der form teilhaben zu
können wie das bisher immer der fall war
ich persönlich mache mir vor allen
dingen auch um die politische
stimmungslage in unserem land sorgen und
der stellvertretende bundestagspräsident
kubicki hat es hier in unserer letzten
sendung vor einer woche schon sehr sehr
deutlich gemacht dass auch er
gesellschaftliche verwerfungen
befürchtet wenn dieser lockdown weiter
anhält also insofern klar corona ohne
frage wir müssen gucken auf die
infektionszahlen wir müssen den
gesundheitsschutz im blick behalte aber
schimpfen bevor wir zu weit weg
bevor wir weiter über die inzidenz zu
sprechen ich habe sehr gefragt wie
enttäuscht sie davon sind das gerade
eben ihre parteikollegen dass ihre
kanzlerin ihr gesundheitsminister ihre
eu kommissionspräsident in das beim
impfen so versammelt haben wie wütend
macht sie dass und was hören sie da auch
in ihrem wahlkreis also ich würde mir
dann natürlich mehr wünschen das gebe
ich offen und ehrlich zu aber herr uns
aber man kann es eben auch nicht nur an
der union fest machen das ist
letztendlich etwas was wir bei allen
regierenden parteien finden dass wir
auch bei den ja auch in den ländern
finden ja sozusagen in den menschen die
dort in regierungsverantwortung sind und
deswegen kann man das auch nicht an
einer person oder an wenigen personen
festmachen das ist letztendlich ein
behörden thema oder ein regierungs thema
das allumfassend ist und insofern
wirklich alle entscheidungsträger in
diesem land betrifft und ich als
parlamentarier möchte möchte natürlich
schon auch die aufgabe die ich
wahrnehmen kann auch ganz aktiv
wahrnehmen und darauf einfluss nehmen
das gebe ich ganz ehrlich zu
herr lindner
hat schuld wenn wir jetzt die letzten
tage beobachtet haben da hat ursula von
der leyen so scheint es zumindest bei
und ex ein bisschen die schuld dem
unternehmen zugeschoben wie haben sie
das beobachtet na das war natürlich
völlig daneben wie übrigens auch die
demonstration die es gegeben hat das
biotec jetzt gewissermaßen enteignet
werden soll
mir ist nicht so sehr an
schuldzuweisungen gelegen das muss
politisch aufgearbeitet werden wird auch
übrigens lieber lars klingbeil die fdp
hat sie im infektionsschutzgesetz nicht
zugestimmt weder im bundestag und unsere
fdp regierungsbeteiligung in den ländern
haben das auch nicht getan weil dieses
gesetz eben keine klare wenn dann regel
beinhaltet es zu unbestimmt und im
übrigen ist die zahl von 35 und 50
politisch gegriffen worden dann ins
gesetz geschrieben worden
diese zahlen haben herrnsheimer
inzwischen auch keine richtige
aussagekraft mehr je mehr menschen
schritt für schritt und viel zu langsam
da sind wir uns einig je mehr menschen
mit einem schweren risiko zu erkranken
geimpft sind desto mehr öffnung muss
auch für die gesellschaft insgesamt
möglich sein
die orientierung die fixierung auf
bundesweit 35 oder 50 würde zu an
dauerhaften lockdown führen am ende zu
einem knockout für das gesellschaftliche
wirtschaftliche und kulturelle leben und
deshalb muss es jetzt eine andere
strategie geben andere zahlen
regionalisiert und vor allen dingen
dürfen wir beim testen nicht das
wiederholen was wir beim impfen nicht
gekannt haben nämlich keine
entschlossene klare entscheidung wir
haben nicht die möglichkeiten unserer
industrie nationen in den dienst des
gesundheitsschutzes gestellt und haben
mit innovativer technologie oder mit
guten verfahren den menschen ihre
freiheit der menschen erwarten die
menschen hätten wir möchten leicht zu
testen natürlich noch mal kommen aber
vorher bei der frage der eröffnung
möchte ich einmal ihnen zeigen was in
schweinfurt los ist denn schweinfurt ist
eine der städte wo die inzidenz
eigentlich so niedrig ist dass man
bereits wieder öffnen können schweinfurt
liegt in bayern
hat eine extrem geringe inzidenz und wir
haben uns in der stadt einmal umgehört
schweinfurt in bayern eine lehre
innenstadt geschlossene geschäfte und
das bei einer niedrig incidents von nur
11,2 stand heute am sonntag egal ob
gastronomie oder textilhandel alle leben
weiterhin dicht bild spricht mit denen
die wie immer am meisten betroffen sind
den einzelhändlern und da niemand der
stadt
wir sind alle ziemlich an unserem limit
angekommen sagt irgendwann mal schluss
mit lustig also dann können wir
dementsprechend für immer schließen
ich würde noch durchhalten bis ende
februar
es geht ohne öffnung geht das so nicht
weiter da war ich ganz klar den
regierenden politiker den vorwurf die ja
letzte woche in ihrer konferenz
ministerpräsidenten und frau merkel
wieder
trotz der vielen guten argumente die wir
gebracht haben und der forderungen
keinen plan keine perspektive für unsere
damen stattdessen wurden wir wieder auf
den siebten dritten vertröstet da könnte
vielleicht bei einer inzidenz und 35 was
passieren also wenn ich ehrlich bin habe
ich eigentlich schon gar kein
verständnis mehr dafür weil es ist
unbegreiflich über uns werde auch noch
nicht mal gesprochen über die
gastronomie wir sind ja immer die
letzten wenn ich sehe was ihnen großen
lebensmittelketten los ist und dort
übereinander gewürfelt auf dem haufen
stehen da passiert gar nichts nicht nur
reden sondern handeln
lasst uns aufmachen gibt uns das geld
was uns zusteht dass wir unsere
mitarbeiter dementsprechend schützen
können und ein bisschen normalität das
wäre super
keine perspektive für die menschen dort
in schweinfurt und wir wollen einmal
sprechen mit herrn jordan vom
lieblingsladen dem klamottenladen der
uns jetzt auch zugeschaltet ist und herr
jordan wenn sie gesehen haben dass
während sie ihren laden geschlossen
halten müssen am wochenende die cdu in
sachsen anhalt einen parteitag
abgehalten hat wo die menschen zusammen
saßen zwar getestet aber in einem raum
was geht ihnen da durch den kopf
also erstmal
eine schönen abend es ist furchtbar muss
ich sagen wir würden alles dafür geben
dass wir gerade in den kleinen läden mit
einzelnen personen die wir dort
hereinholen
ein schönes einkaufserlebnis machen
können und das wird uns verwehrt und im
gleichen atemzug sieht man
menschenmassen politisch zusammen sitzen
und dort sachen zu besprechen wie
erklären sie sich dass das dann auf der
anderen seite eben in der politik so ein
parteitag abgehalten wird aber ihn seit
wochen monaten muss man sagen
mittlerweile in den vierten monat gesagt
wird nein wir können nicht öffnen die
zahlen lassen das nicht zu man kann da
gar keine worte finden also man muss
einfach mal an uns denken man muss an
die mitarbeiter denken diese leute
stehen in dem laden drin oder sollten im
laden stehen und wissen gar nicht mehr
von interesse sind manchmal
mitarbeiterinnen die alleine sind
wirklichen kurzarbeiter entgelt und
diese menschen werden ganz gesehen die
wirklich ängste haben und im gleichen
atemzug wie gesagt sieht man da diese
leute zu machen und sich besprechen und
sich unterhalten
ganz ganz ganz furchtbar er klingt
furchtbar sagte jordaan
haben sie die normalen menschen die
gerade um ihren lebensunterhalt kämpfen
um ihre geschäfte kämpfen darum endlich
wieder zu arbeiten haben sie nie
vergessen
nein die haben nicht vergessen
nochmal ich kann heute hier auch keine
cdu parteitage bewährten ja darum geht
es für mich gerade nicht weil ich nicht
genau weiß was da passiert ist nicht für
mich
um die frage kümmern und da mache ich
druck dass wir öffnungs perspektiven
bekommen das was wir getan haben in den
letzten monaten ist dass wir versucht
haben abzumildern durch
wirtschaftshilfen die auch vom bund
zahlt gleich zur verfügung gestellt
wurden auch von ländern aber nochmal ist
muss jetzt nach einem jahr des lok downs
mussten die frage gehen unter welchen
bedingungen kann öffnen es gibt kluge
test konzepte es gibt es impfen das mit
viel zu langsam voran geht da würde ich
verschicke auch widersprechen dass man
dass man keine kritik üben darf ich
finde die kann gar nicht laut genug sein
da muss mehr druck rein das impfen das
erreichen was andere länder viel besser
gemacht haben dass sie impfstoff
bestellt haben dass sie beim impfen noch
schneller
vorankommen also das findet wenn wir als
parlamentarier nicht kritisch sind dann
kommt doch gar kein druck rein bei
dieser frage aber wenn sie das vor allem
als perspektive sprechen das benutzen
sie ja seit wochen und monaten und immer
wieder machen sie da den menschen
hoffnung und dann geht es zu einen mpk
und zur nächsten mpk und am ende kommt
immer nichts bei raus sondern weitere
verschärfungen oder zumindest die
fortsetzung des lok down wie können sie
denn jetzt den jordan wirklich mal
hoffnung machen sagen sie anfang märz
gibt's dann konkrete schritte wann er
wieder aufmachen darf das ist das was
klar verabredet ist dass die
ministerpräsidenten auf der nächsten
runde mit der mit der bundeskanzlerin
die anfang märz stattfindet genau über
diese frage reden wo sind eigentlich die
werte und die kriterien ab landes welche
öffnung gibt natürlich muss man auch
dann immer klar sagen wird damit dazu ab
wann kommt es dann vielleicht auch
wieder zu schließungen bei welchen
werten aber diese klarheit muss da sein
aber aus ihrer sicht auch so empfinden
darf ich dir zu entsprechen bei den
verlieren wir glaube ich ein teil auch
der bevölkerung die gerade großes
fragezeichen an so manche politische
entscheidung machen aber ganz konkret
jetzt bei jordan wenn sie sich die
inzidenz dort anschauen darf man bei
unter 20 aus ihrer sicht sollte man da
öffnen dürfen
wir haben doch sogar schon auch konzepte
vorliegen wenn ich auf meinem bundesland
niedersachsen gucke da gibt es die frage
ob einzeln angehen ich auch schon viel
früher aufmachen kann wieder natürlich
alles noch mit ihren konzepten mit
abstand und so weiter und so fort
aber da sind doch viele einzelhändler
auch in der lage das durchzusetzen das
umzusetzen natürlich muss es diese
perspektive gibt kann man aufpassen muss
und ich weiß nicht ob ich christian
lindner richtig verstanden habe ist die
frage der regionalisierung also main
landkreis hat auch instanzen die liegen
um die 20 aber wenn ich da in einem
landkreis in einzelhandel ausmacht oder
die gastronomie auf mache dann kommen
doch alles den nachbarlandkreis über
also ich glaube diese regionalität muss
man schon stark auch in betracht ziehen
und muss gucken wir hatten die situation
mit den gartencentern mit den baumärkten
wo dann alle auch in die
nachbarlandkreise gefahren sind das kann
auch nicht sinn der sache sein
aber es gibt mittlerweile also keine
regionale währung auch über das doch
aber das kann mehr als landkreis sein
dass meine ich damit
es muss unter den landkreisen noch
abgestimmt sein wie man da vorgeht
herr jordan zum anschluss an sie die
frage was würden sie sich jetzt von der
politik wünschen an konkreten aussagen
dann kommen wir auch gleich den linden
aber was wäre ihr wunsch abschließend
hier in dieser runde an die politik
meine wünsche ich glaube die kennen die
politik politiker sehr sehr genau ich
denke man muss uns jetzt die möglichkeit
geben selbst wieder das zepter in die
hand zu nehmen wie gesagt an den hilfen
scheitert er auch und da müssen wir
selber der lager seien einfach unser
unternehmen unsere mitarbeiter zu
schützen einfach wieder schrittweise auf
zu machen natürlich mit schutzmaßnahmen
aber ich denke mal das ist bei so
kleinen unternehmen wie wir uns kein
problem wir können das und wir konnten
das auch schon und einfach nur uns unser
unternehmen führen das denn bitte wieder
herr lindner haben sie das gefühl dass
in der bundesregierung den anfang märz
tatsächlich mal über öffnungen
gesprochen wird oder wenn man sich die
zahlen anschauen geht dass er wieder an
die gegenteilige richtung weil dann
immer wieder von der mutation die rede
ist ich bin im zweifel wenn ich höre was
frau merkel was der kanzleramtschef
braun sagt wenn ich den vorsitzenden der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion herrn
brinkhaus höre habe ich den eindruck die
wollen er noch von der 35 auf die zehn
runter bevor es irgendwelche öffnungs
schritte gibt im fall schweinfurt und
von herrn jordan muss man sagen dass ich
bewundere wie ruhig und gefasst er hier
auftritt bei einer inzidenz von 11 sind
die jetzigen freiheits einschränkungen
in dieser stadt absolut
unverhältnismäßig und ich glaube dass
dort auch der grundsatz unserer
verfassung dass die regierung nur die
maßnahmen wählen darf die wirklich
erforderlich und geeignet sind das der
in frage steht das ist möglicherweise
jetzt schon eine rechtsfrage so
drastisch ist die freiheitseinschränkung
dort und anders gewendet unter einer
inzidenz von 50 die einigermaßen stabil
ist sollte in deutschland überall in
jedem landkreis in jeder stadt der
handel und anderes auch mit schutz
konzepten öffnen
der skandal ist nicht der cdu-parteitag
in sachsen anhalt das problem ist dass
ähnliche bedingungen
nicht auch für andere gesellschaftliche
bereiche gelten wenn man sich schützen
kann dann nicht nur beim friseurin auf
dem parteitag sondern auch im handel und
in der gastronomie
washington sie als cdu abgeordnete als
stellvertretende vorsitzende der
mittelstands-union können sie menschen
wie jordan hoffnung machen dass sie
jetzt druck auslösen auf die kanzlerin
auf das was da bei der mpk passiert auch
die ministerpräsidenten wie können sie
diesen menschen hoffnung machen
naja die menschen sind zunächst einmal
froh wenn man sich für sie zeit nimmt
und ihn überhaupt zu hören
das erleben sie nämlich nicht so oft und
auch die branchen die sich alle schon
seit längerem auch an uns dann von der
politik wenden
könig davon reden dass man auf ihre
ideen und vorschläge bisher gehört hat
und das wünsche ich mir natürlich
versucht das muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen
immer auch durch meine persönlichkeit
natürlich auch darzulegen wie wir
kämpfen wie wir argumentieren wie wir
die realität die wir vor ort erleben
wirklich auch in den bundestag tragen
aber am ende sie wissen es entscheidet
ist die regierung wir als parlament
haben die bayern respekt zumal doch bei
allem respekt vor stimmte aber sie haben
doch die möglichkeit in ihrer cdu druck
zu machen sie haben in einer sitzung
einmal gesagt dass sie das gefühl haben
bei einigen die situation einer wende 20
zu erleben
also da scheinen die menschen ja
wahnsinnig verzweifelt da müssen sie
doch mehr tun als einfach nur zuhören
sondern da müssten sie eigentlich im
bundestag aufstehen und zur kanzlerin
laufen und immer erzählen wie sie in
ihrem wahlkreis aussieht oder richtig
das habe ich ja gerade eben versucht
auch deutlich zu machen es sind zwei
jahr der dinge ob auf der einen seite
kümmern wir uns hier um die menschen vor
ort und auf der anderen seite tragen wir
natürlich das was uns hier gesagt wird
in aller offenheit und aller ehrlichkeit
auch an unsere regierung an unsere
regierenden fraktionsmitglieder in den
deutschen bundestag das sage ich auch so
ganz klar und öffentlich dort vor ort
das tue ich
der ehemalige spd vorsitzende und
vizekanzler sigmar gabriel hat diese
woche beklagt ich zitiere wir behandeln
die pandemie mit den mitteln des
mittelalters bei der pest wurden
menschen auch nur weggesperrt die mittel
des 21 jahrhunderts lassen wir aber
weitgehend ungenutzt liegen das ist ja
eine massive kritik eines ehemaligen
vizekanzler ist eines ehemaligen
spd-chefs warum kriegen sie es nicht
denn sie sind auch digital politiker
sind da in der spd als digital experte
groß geworden warum schaffen wir das in
deutschland nicht warum stehen wir
überall hinten nicht nur beim impfen
sondern eben auch bei der
digitalisierung der gesundheitsämter bei
allen schritten die wichtig sind warum
sind wir da so unglaublich schlecht also
erst finde ich ja ganz spannend dass
wenn man/frau schild gezögert hat man
das gefühl sie hat mit der mit der cdu
gar nichts zu tun ja das ist schon sehr
spannend dass es an dieser stelle nicht
auf das eingegangen wird was unsere
parteien hier auch zusammen in der
regierung entscheiden was ihre frage
angeht der ronzheimer und ich sind wir
sehr gut gestartet in dieser partie ich
finde wir haben auch es geschafft als
deutschland einen vorsprung zu haben
aber in der tat wir kreieren grad an
vielen stellen diesen vorschlägen den
wir hatten und ich will es noch mal
betonen impfen weil der erste punkt an
dem wir forschung verloren haben jetzt
reden wir seien in den nächsten
nachteilen beim testen aber auch die
frage digitalisierung der schulen die
rheinländer verantwortlichkeit liegt
aber frau carlitscheck macht jetzt
morgen also am montag ein gipfel zur
digitalen bildung ein gerne ausbruch der
pandemie und auch bei der frage
ausstattung der gesundheitsämter sind
wir glaube ich vorangekommen in den
letzten wochen allerdings in
trippelschritten also in kleinen
schritten und wir brauchen dringend neue
möglichkeiten auch der digitalen
nachverfolgung ich bin froh dass die
korona war nett dass sie immer noch
überarbeitet wird aber es muss viel mehr
passieren als dass gerade der fall ist
haben sie recht stichwort testen
erklingen bei sie sagen das könnte der
nächste große reinfall werden wir wollen
seine man schauen was der
gesundheitsminister jens spahn
versprochen hat beim thema testen
unser vorschlag sie ab märz kostenlos
für die bürgerinnen und bürger ein
schnelltest möglich zu machen
herr lindner glauben sie dass der
gesundheitsminister dieses versprechen
halten kann
erst wenn ich sehe dass heißt sie
glauben nicht daran
wir haben so viele ankündigungen erlebt
so viele enttäuschungen zahlen werden
genannt zahlen werden korrigiert ich
glaube dinge erst nur noch wenn ich sie
wirklich sehr wenn wir uns das anschauen
insbesondere jens spahn hat ja immer
wieder verschiedene daten genannt
da ging es um die pflegeheime war die
durch geimpft sind wir erinnern uns auch
an die besten diskussion insgesamt beim
thema ist wahnsinnig viel schiefgegangen
wundern sie sich eigentlich dass
offenbar niemand mehr in dieser
regierung verantwortung übernehmen will
und dann am ende aus sagt mensch das war
mein fehler oder sogar über rücktritt
nachdenkt und was ist wenn jetzt auch
das schiefgeht glauben sie dass jens
spahn dann daraus konsequenzen ziehen
muss
nein das glaube ich nicht denn die lage
ist doch so herrnsheimer es hört man
hört immer viel kritik und gute
vorschläge beispielsweise die
ministerpräsidentin von rheinland-pfalz
frau drei heiß heute mit sehr guten
aussagen auch in den medien wieder
präsent zum thema testen
aber dann kommt die runde zusammen von
kanzlerin und ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidenten an frau merkel
drückt ihre position durch frau schimke
tritt hier selbstbewusst auf mit klugen
aussagen aber im deutschen bundestag
tritt herr brinkhaus ans pult und der
will er noch eine instanz von zehn statt
wenn also nicht im kreis der
regierungschefin und chefs und
insbesondere innerhalb der cdu endlich
klartext gesprochen wird dass man
gesundheit nicht dauerhaft gegen bildung
kultur und wirtschaft ausspielen da die
ist das kanzleramt macht dann glaube ich
haben wir ein problem irgendwann auch
der legitimation der politik insgesamt
bestimmte wie wütend sind die menschen
wenn sie mit ihnen sprechen darüber was
schief läuft was gesundheitsministerien
sparen verspricht was die kanzlerin
sachen locker und sagt wer was was hören
sie da
naja also man hat auf der einen seite
die großen existenzängste bei den
unternehmerinnen unternehmer man hat den
frust man hat die die enttäuschung den
ärger auch bei den senioren wegen der
ganzen impftermine und weil das alles
nicht klappt man hat zunehmend auch
wirklich eine tiefe traurigkeit bei den
leuten zu hause weil sie eben ein paar
ihrer angehörigen nicht treffen und das
ganze verwandelt sich inzwischen in so
einer art in resignation aber auch aber
auch aber auch wut also das muss ich
ganz ehrlich sagen also wir leben auch
wut vor ort und dann immer so auch diese
aussagen ja bei der nächsten wahl darf
er dann mal eine andere entscheidung
treffen als bisher
und das gibt mir persönlich unglaublich
zu denken ja müssen sollte der große
sorgen sie sagen sie machen sich große
sorgen aber warum zieht dann keiner
verantwortung denken sie dass wenn das
schiefgeht mit diesen massentest jens
spahn über einen rücktritt nachdenken
muss ich habe manchmal das gefühl dass
die erkenntnis in denen entscheider
kreisen so gar nicht da ist also dass
wir ein stück weit eine andere
lebensrealitäten andere
lebenswirklichkeit haben als jene die
jetzt in der bundesregierung eben solche
wichtigen entscheidungen treffen und ich
habe ja immer die hoffnung dass das was
wir vor ort erleben und dann auch im
gespräch mit unseren kolleginnen und
kollegen im bundestag auch diskutieren
dass das eine wirkung erzielt und
nochmal ganz konkreten können es ganz
konkret meine frage wenn das wieder
schiefgeht mit diesen massentest auf die
wir gleich noch mal im detail kommen
sollte dann jemand zurücktreten und
endlich mal verantwortung übernehmen für
diese pleiten pech und pannen in der
bundesregierung
finden sie das nicht ein bisschen zu
einfach wirklich in der hochphase einer
krise jetzt die pferde zu wechseln also
ich weiß nicht ob das die richtige
lösung ist am ende dass ich finde ich
finde dass die menschen merkten im
vergleich zu früheren jahren wo
politiker die verantwortung übernommen
haben dann auch für fehler dass das
jetzt immer mit ausrede krise als
beglichen gilt na gut aber wir haben
doch eines gelernt in der vergangenheit
dass fehler die gemacht werden nicht
immer nur auf eine einzige person
zurückzuführen sondern gibst du kannst
von der leyen da gibt es ja sparen ich
könnte ihn noch ein paar mehr aufzählen
die können doch nicht auf einmal alle
das geht ja nicht nein also wir müssen
schon gucken dass wir durch die krise
durch kommen also dann muss man auch ein
bisschen robust sein und mir ist wichtig
dass die herrschaften auch beratung
annehmen ja und kritik auch annehmen das
ist das ganz entscheidende wenn man in
so einer position sitzt und also ich
muss auch ganz ehrlich sagen viel
schlimmer als fehler zu machen finde ich
wenn man wenn man den politischen willen
etwas zu ändern nicht hat das halte ich
persönlich für viel schwerwiegender als
zu sagen okay wir versuchen etwas wir
haben den festen willen die situation zu
verbessern und es passieren auch fehler
wir müssen auch eine fehler toleranz
haben na klar politischen willen sie
sprechen das anfangs schimke ich möchte
ihnen einmal zeigen was in österreich
passiert ist und dort die schulen wieder
aufzumachen denn dort hat man einfach
beherzt gesagt wir machen diese
testreihe das heißt puppe test in
österreich oder auch lolli test den die
kinder dort selbst machen können das
funktioniert seit mehreren wochen und in
österreich sind so sehr sehr viele
positive ergebnisse herausgekommen und
gleichzeitig funktioniert der
schulbetrieb wieder viel viel besser
oder als hier in deutschland
denn wenn wir sehen dass dort alle
klassen natürlich im wechsel und mit
abstand wieder unterricht machen können
ich habe dazu vorher mit dem
bildungsminister aus österreich herrn
fassmann gesprochen wäre testen wirklich
viel wir testen in etwa seit mitte
januar februar auch in den schulen
flächig schüler und schülerinnen werden
bei uns zwei mal in der woche getestet
mit einem ganz niederschwelligen test
bei der materie zahlen antigen test wohl
nur der untere nasenbereich mit einem
wattestäbchen abgefahren werden muss wir
wollen damit sozusagen schulische
breakouts verhindern also schüler und
schülerinnen die wirklich infiziert sind
die sprayer sind und die glaube ich
können wir mit dieser maßnahme aus dem
schulischen geschehen herausnehmen und
damit so etwas wie normalbetrieb in der
schule gewährleisten
also nicht in dieser art und weise wir
haben ja doch in der primarstufe die
gesamte schüler anzahl in die schule
zurück gebracht und in der schule der
zehn- und mehrjährigen über einen
wechsel unterricht also da ist schon die
quantität wieder in der schulgebäude
zurückgekommen und das testen ist eine
von drei sicherheitsmaßnahmen
schichtbetrieb wechsel unterricht ist
die zweite sicherheitsmassnahme und das
tragen von mund nasen schutz von maske
ab dem 10 jährigen ist die dritte
sicherheitsmaßnahme aber ohne tests
hätten wir es glaube ich innerhalb der
bundesregierung nicht zusammengebracht
auch die akzeptanz von
gesundheitsminister zu bekommen
die schule wieder zu eröffnen aber das
wesentliche ist ja wir testen wie gesagt
zwei mal in der woche
und wir wissen dass wir jene
identifizieren können mit einer frohen
virus last also die tatsächlich
infektiös sind und er vielleicht am
montag noch nicht infektiös ist dabei
infiziert da entwickelt sich das
vielleicht bis mittwoch so weit dass
auch unser test an schlägt also wir
müssen wissen dass sie nicht so präzise
sind aber sie sind eine ein wirkliches
instrument um das trading in der klasse
zu verhindern
es gibt vielleicht noch eine andere
nachricht die man auch immer anbringen
muss während negativ getestet ist möge
sich nicht in sicherheit wiegen
aber das vermitteln wir auch in vielen
unserer öffentlichen botschaften das
negative testergebnis kann sich in
kurzer zeit doch wieder ändern
daher ist das tragen der maske in der
schule ein weiteres muss ja spannende
insights von heinz fassmann den
bildungsminister und wenn wir jetzt
darauf schauen dass am montag die
schulen wieder öffnen eine frau schimke
und her klingbeil wenn sie das hören
dass ohne test dann weitergemacht wird
also dass wir kein test haben obwohl in
österreich man sagt man sollte die
schule nur öffnen wenn man auch testete
klingbeil ist das dann richtig dass wir
am montag die schulen wieder staaten
ohne dieses testverfahren es ist richtig
dass wir die schulen wieder starten und
zwar bei den werten die wir haben ich
habe es vorhin erwähnt wenn ihr im
landkreis komfort um die 20 und sind
niedersachsen generell niedrig deswegen
ist es gut dass die bildung endlich
wieder losgeht für die kids dass das ist
ja alles eine sache die wir viel
diskutiert haben auch in den letzten
wochen was ich mir wünsche sind
allerdings zwei sachen sein ist dass wir
lehrer übrigens auch erzieherinnen und
erzieher dass wir die vorziehen beim
impfen
und das zweite ist wir brauchen jetzt
genau das was in österreich passiert
nämlich diese tests müssen schnell in
den schulen durchgeführt werden das gibt
mir sicherheit und das aber warum mehr
möglichkeiten das krone virus im griff
zeiten aber warum ist österreich
schneller als deutschland in dem fall
verstehen sie das ich verstehe es
insofern dass das gesundheitsministerium
erklärt hat sie wollen hier die
zulassung die muss über staatliche
stellen auch gegeben werden das dauert
jetzt noch bis in den anfang märz hinein
aber dann haben wir diese zulassung auch
aber das ist die erklärung des
gesundheitsministeriums
herr lindner können sie diese ausreden
noch verstehen die da aus dem
gesundheitsministerium kommen oder von
anderer stelle der regierung war um mal
wieder irgendetwas nicht möglich ist und
wir uns gleichzeitig die schulen öffnen
aber eben keine tests machen
nein ich kann das nicht verstehen wir
haben die erste chance auf einen
strategiewechsel beim impfen verpasst
und sind jetzt dabei auch die zweite
große chance durch die schnell und
selbsttests zu verstolpern
da geht es für mich nicht nur um die
schulen der ronzheimer sondern für mich
ist ein paket unter anderem mit dem test
auch mit maske auch mit hygiene konzept
digitalisierung des gesundheitswesens
dem schutz der wirklich gefährdeten
menschen das ist für mich ein paket das
über die schule hinaus mehr
gesellschaftliches kulturelles leben
ermöglichen kann
und für meinen geschmack konzentriert
sich die bundesregierung viel zu stark
auf die strategie wir bleiben zu hause
auf die fortsetzung des lockouts wir
hangeln uns von einem beschluss zum
nächsten das muss jetzt beendet werden
wir brauchen jetzt eine verlässliche
öffnungszeiten für das land mindestens
wenn dann regeln unter denen die
menschen dann verstehen wenn man
diszipliniert und diszipliniert und
verantwortungsbewusst ist dann gibt es
für alle auch mehr freiheit
das ist inzwischen für unser land eine
frage wirklich der politischen akzeptanz
die menschen gehen sonst der politik von
der fahne vor sinke würden sie ihre
kinder in die schule schicken ohne so
test wie es da in österreich gibt und
können sie das verstehen warum es das
bei uns doch nicht gibt
also ich finde die schulen hätten in
deutschland nie so lange geschlossen
werden dürfen
ich mache mir große sorgen um die
zukunft unserer kinder ich habe meine
kinder selbst auch immer in die kita
geschickt wenn das möglich war und ich
halte das auch für richtig allerdings
und das sehen wir natürlich jetzt in
österreich man verbindet das ganze mit
einer sehr intelligenten test strategie
und ich finde da wir jetzt alle uns
einig sind dass das eine gute sache ist
sollte doch jetzt auch die politik
reagieren und schnellstmöglich das auch
in deutschland einrichten das finde ich
ist das mindeste was wir erwarten können
und wir möchten sprechen mit jemandem
der schon sehr sehr lange testet wie in
österreich gehören schittenhelm der im
landkreis böblingen etwas ähnliches wie
österreich geschafft hat zumindest auf
lokaler ebene herrscht schön dass sie
zeit finden trotz der intensiven test
die sie durchführen in ihrer apotheke
mit ihrer apotheke wenn sie sich das
anschauen was gesundheitsministeriums
sparender versprochen hat nämlich diese
schnelltests für alle glauben sie das
funktioniert und wie steht deutschland
insgesamt da aus ihrer sicht vielen dank
für die einladung prinzipiell ist die
entscheidung natürlich richtig und gut
von der spar getroffen zu werden
allerdings kommt sie meines erachtens
deutlich zu spät und wieder einmal quasi
werden die apotheke vor die wahl
gestellt innerhalb von kürzester zeit
jetzt über das stöckchen zu springen und
quasi das thema zu stemmen den ärzten
geht es genauso
dementsprechend muss man einfach
konstatieren die bundesregierung hat sie
schnell dass strategie etwas verschlafen
wir haben versucht schon im dezember
anzufangen sie sind bei uns gestartet im
kreis haben im schnelltest zentren mit
der mit dem kreis mit dem landkreis eben
ein gerichten zusammen mit fünf kollegen
betreiben wir haben letzte woche lieber
als 6000 tests gemacht
davon hatten wir wieder 25 positive die
wir aussortieren können
der test ist dank
unseres landkreises bei uns in der
zweiten woche schon gratis also wir
machen das was österreich schon tot im
kleinen schwäbischen rahmen und das ist
glaube ich durchaus interessant und bis
jetzt hat leider die bundespolitik noch
nicht so auf den landkreis böblingen
geschaut ich denke das was wir vor
machen könnte vorbild für den bund sein
aber das ist eben diese infrastrukturen
das ist das grundproblem was sie
ansprechen ich glaube beim impfen haben
wir die habe nicht mehr weltmeisterliche
infrastruktur geschaffen
da sind wir top aufgestellt wir haben
doch kein impfstoff und bei den
schnelltest ist es glaube ich genau
umgekehrt haben wir eine katastrophale
infrastruktur aber wir haben jede menge
schnelltest in deutschland der letzte
woche im welt interview gesagt ich
könnte locker eine million das bestellen
inzwischen aufgrund der medialen präsenz
die auf uns kommt muss ich die zahl
korrigieren ich würde sagen mit den
kontakten die mir jetzt dazu gestellt
werden könnte zehn millionen tester
bekommen also da muss man ganz klar
sagen dass wurde ein bisschen top end
und das ist das was nicht auch ein
bisschen weh tut weil wir eigentlich in
der ersten welle sind nur so gut
durchgekommen deutschland stand so gut
da und die zweite welle aber komplett
verschlafen wir apotheker musste es
wieder ausbaden bei den masken
da hatten wir auch wieder drei tage zeit
400 millionen masken zu besorgen jetzt
geht es ähnlich wir haben eine woche
zeit schnell testzentren aufzubauen und
das ist einfach wir machen das gerne wir
nehmen die aufgabe an und ich bin auch
davon überzeugt wir kriegen das hin
gehen baden württemberg also ist
deutschland kein high tech land in der
frage was die bekämpfung der angeht
unterstellte das angeht definitiv nicht
da sind wir ganz klar österreich
hinterher das hatten sie wunderbar
gesehen ich war letzte woche auch beim
krisen gibt die landesregierung
eingeladen und aber auch mit österreich
als pilot modell da haben wir die ohren
geschnackt die haben das ist drei säulen
modell was gerade angesprochen wurde
was wirklich sehr gut funktioniert wie
gesagt wir brauchen dringend jetzt diese
schnelltests zentren als infrastruktur
wir brauchen auch möglichst schnell man
im internationalen vergleich aus ihrer
sicht sind wieder näher entwicklungsland
da sehen wir definitiv ein schnelltest
angehende entwicklungsland da sind wir
ganz hinten also auch europaweit andere
länder waren viel schneller in
frankreich in italien überall durften
apotheken schon seit wochen und monaten
zum teil halbes jahr lang testen teilen
sie das rea blicken ein ja der länder
wenn sie das hören beim testen sind wir
entwicklungsland was erwartet uns dann
in den nächsten wochen aus ihrer sicht
noch für weitere schreckensnachrichten
und was können wir von irgendwelchen
versprechen noch halten
das ist nun durch eine sehr schwierige
frage
ich wünsche mir einfach einen anderen
umgang mit der pandemie herrnsheimer
dass wir dazu übergehen einmal nicht von
tag zu tag zu denken sondern das ist
eine gewissermaßen strategische
voraussicht gibt was werden die nächsten
phasen seien in die wir kommen ja also
sommerferien oder osterferien die kommen
nicht überraschend
änderungen der jahreszeiten kommen nicht
überraschend und darauf müssen wir uns
besser vorbereiten
im grunde haben wir auch alle optionen
jetzt auf der hand wir haben das impfen
und den impfstoff mit den beschriebenen
problemen wir haben die tests mit den
beschriebenen problemen wir müssten noch
sprechen über luftreiniger deren
potenzial ist noch nicht ausgeschöpft
bei der digitalisierung des
gesundheitswesens gibt es schlechte
nachrichten dass nicht alle
gesundheitsämter sich in die zentrale
plattform mit einschalten wollen daran
wäre zu arbeiten aber wir müssen mal weg
kommen von diesem weil wir nur von tag
zu tag planen gibt es nur eine
möglichkeit nämlich alles nicht machen
den menschen angst machen und dann das
land nicht machen daraus müssen wir uns
befreien weil der soziale und
wirtschaftliche schaden inzwischen
untragbar geworden ist erklingt beim
testen entwicklungsland was kommt da auf
uns zu und wenn sie das jetzt hören aus
der praxis ein mann der das seit wochen
und monaten macht und dass er sehr
plastisch erzählt hat wie viel es dann
davon zu halten was der
gesundheitsminister versprochen hat also
erstmal ziehe ich meinen hut davor was
da in böblingen im landkreis passiert
dass es da sind macher und sagen am
arbeiten und zeigen ja auch dass es geht
und ich wünsche mir wirklich dass die
ankündigung von hier entspannen das ist
zum ersten märz klappt das alles
kostenfrei geimpft werden getestet
werden können dass es funktioniert nur
ich sag ihnen auch beim thema impfen
haben wir gemerkt können wir den
ankündigung von ihren sparen nicht
glauben da wird jetzt immer weiter
korrigiert und korrigierten daten werden
nach hinten geschoben und ich habe ein
bisschen angst dass wir die nächste
richtung schaffen also bei mir im
wahlkreis standen die leute schon auf
der matte und wollten wissen wo sie denn
genau am ersten märz sich tests lassen
können das ist für viele ja ganz wichtig
wenn sie zum beispiel zu den eltern
fahren oder wenn sie unterwegs sind auch
beruflich unterwegs sind also wo kann
man das eigentlich machen soll und da
sind viele fragen die hier entspannt es
sollte überhaupt nicht beantwortet hat
also genau die fragen anderer warum
warum trainer für st
warum trägst du warum fragen sie mich
nachdem ich ja der koalitionspartner
schön natürlich drängen wir aber wir
haben jetzt das ist die ist es im
kabinett ist ein crooner kabinett da
werden diese dinge besprochen sie haben
heute vielleicht auch das interview von
malu dreyer gelesen die den druck aus
den ländern macht wird machen doch druck
aber am ende ist es doch eine frage auch
ob jens spahn seine seine politischen
vorhaben per twitter verkündet oder ob
man das auf ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
und ob man das im kabinett ob man das in
der wunde auch mit den
gesundheitsministern der länder macht
und dort dinge ordentlich vorbereitet
und ich erlebe jetzt dass ihr politik
per twitter gemacht wird und in einer
phase wo wir vertrauen verloren haben
weil es nicht funktioniert da jetzt das
nächste und top zu setzen das läuft eine
große gefahr dass wieder vertrauen
verloren geht und ich wünsche mir dass
hier entspannen des hinkriegt zum ersten
märz es wird nicht daran scheitern dass
die spd nicht unterstützt oder das will
ich ausreichend druck machen aber das
sind noch zehn tage und wir haben gerade
gehört was für eine wahnsinns
infrastruktur aufgebaut werden mussten
ich befürchte es gibt wieder
enttäuschungen am ersten märz woche gibt
es wieder enttäuschungen am ersten märz
und wo bleibt diese nationale
kraftanstrengung beim impfen
die da aus dem gesundheitsministerium
erklärt wurde und was wir immer wieder
hören die menschen denken doch
irgendwann die politiker insgesamt
wollen sie irgendwie verlinkt veräppeln
wenn dann am ende das ergebnis nicht
gehalten wird ja also ich hoffe
natürlich dass wir es mit einem lang zu
tun haben dass lernfähig ist das aus
fehlern lernt und das versucht dinge
besser zu machen schauen sie ich bin ja
bei diesen ganzen sachen nicht dabei als
parlamentarierin ich sitze
nicht im krisenstab oder oder oder in
einer verhandlungsrunde mit den ländern
ja also ich kann mir das auch
letztendlich alles immer nur von außen
anschauen und versuchen auch den discos
zu suchen mit unseren
entscheidungsträgern und das auch immer
wieder in diese runde zu geben und zu
sagen was jetzt nötig ist ja einfach
auch die sicht von vor ort auch mal rein
zu tragen und ich habe einfach die
hoffnung dass man inzwischen aus fehlern
gelernt hat und das ist glaubt herr
lindner
glauben sie dass es klappt es keine
glaubensfrage ich würde auch keine
prognose abgeben die demotivierend
wirken würde ich wünsche mir auch dass
es gelingt und dass wir insgesamt zu
einem strategiewechsel kommen
vielleicht wäre es ein guter rat wenn
schon in dieser woche die kanzlerin mit
den regierungschefin und chefs der
länder zusammenkommen um über einen
öffnungs klar zu sprechen und darüber
wie wir beim testen schneller werden
hecking bahn hat recht es keine sache
für twitter sondern für eine beratung
von bund und ländern damit es gelingen
kann
mein wunsch ist zudem dass die
kolleginnen und kollegen der cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion auch noch stärker
ihre praxis eindrücke in die politik
einbringen
es wird hier viel gesprochen über die
kanzlerin und über den
gesundheitsminister aber ich habe mich
erinnert das einmal innerhalb der cdu
csu bundestagsfraktion ein neuer
vorsitzender gewählt worden ist weil man
nicht mehr so eine art verlängerte
werkbank des kanzleramts sein wollte
da wurde herr brinkhaus lang gewählt da
müsste doch jetzt dann die möglichkeit
bestehen dass roche imk und andere auf
diesen ihren neuen vorsitzenden zu gehen
und beschreiben was sache ist bislang
erlebe ich an brinkhaus in den
bundestagsdebatten so dass er die
opposition die fragen stellt kritisch
würdigt sage ich einmal diplomatisch
aber ansonsten den kurs des kanzleramts
nicht nur verteidigt sondern eher noch
eine verschärfung will wenn es nach der
spitze der cdu csu bundestagsfraktion
geht dann würde es ja nicht in die
richtung von frau schimke gehen sondern
im gegenteil sie würden ja noch mehr
dicht machen und da muss die cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion sich selbst die frage
stellen welche strategie verfolgt
wirklich sie und wie wirkt sie auf die
von ihr getragene regierung ein
fortschritte gibt es einen aufstand
gegen herrn brinkhaus und wenn sie dann
mal klar ihre meinung sagen warum
bundestag
also wir sagen unsere meinung aber
deswegen müssen wir keinen aufstand
proben also wir reden miteinander
wir diskutieren miteinander und ich habe
auch das gefühl dass der
fraktionsvorsitzende sehr genau weiß was
vor ort los ist und er hat keinen
leichten job das gebe ich ehrlich zu und
wir unterstützen ihn auch nach kräften
ich möchte noch eine weitere stimme hier
mit in die runde nehmen denn was der
apotheker sydney bei den test ist das
ist oder das sind die rapper
fantastischen vier im bereich der korona
er uns ist jetzt zugeschaltet motto der
mitentwickelt hat eine app mit dem namen
luca die aus vielerlei gründen besser
ist offenbar als die die vom bund
entwickelt wurde das motto was können
sie uns sagen warum ist ihre app besser
und warum sollte deutschland sich
umrüsten oder dafür interessieren schön
oder haben zusammen also erstmal sie
reden glaube ich bin der caravan app
damit haben wir gar nichts zu tun das
sind zwei ganz verschiedene dinge
ich möchte ja auch ganz klar stellen
dass wir nicht besser oder schlechter
sind das sind zwei verschiedene sachen
die karawane pisten individuelle radert
ein individuelles risiko bemisst dies
mit absicht passiv läuft im hintergrund
darf daten nicht aufzeichnen luca
hingegen ist nicht nur die unsere app
ist nicht nur eine app sollen ein system
da geht es im prinzip oder
digitalisierung der
dokumentationspflicht spricht dass man
seinen namen irgendwo hinterlassen muss
nur in diesem fall ist es so dass sie
auf jeden fall ihre telefonnummer schon
mal richtig haben bei der registrierung
wird man da angemeldet und einer
quittung sms es wird aber nicht eine
historie angelegt wurde mit einem
minütlich wechsel im qr code in
locations einchecken kann restaurants
oder ins theater oder auf eine tribüne
in einem stadion wo man eine kohorte von
50 oder 100 leuten hätte und so entsteht
ein kontakt tagebuch das ist nicht das
einzige soll das jetzt seine infektion
kommen dann wird das weil das ist
erstmal alles verschlüsselt und in die
man kann die daten ran auch nicht der
betreiber
wenn das gesundheitsamt jemanden einen
infizierten feststellt dann rufen sie an
fragen hast du luca dann sagte er ja
dann gibt ja einen tag frei wenn er das
möchte damit gibt es eine historie frei
und damit können alle anderen die im
risiko sind automatisch gewarnt
werden brauchen theoretisch noch nicht
mal eine andere vom gesundheitsamt das
ist das eine
es ist aber auch möglich cross zu großen
und das ist eigentlich der zauberball
erfassungs apps gibt es viele aber luca
ist die einzige die einen kanal sind als
amt hat einmal ganz konkret war ganz
konkret was wäre aus ihrer sicht mit der
app die sie damit entwickelt haben
wieder möglich was momentan nicht
möglich ist ganz konkret ist es so dass
es eine app ist die in die vergangenheit
gucken nicht die zukunft die jetzige
dokumentationspflicht die bildet ab was
machen wir in einer krank ist was muss
er machen damit er nicht künftig weitere
ansteckt wir können zurück gucken und
können schauen wen hat er in der
vergangenheit dann auch noch angesteckt
so lassen sich quell cluster finden weil
nur einer von zehn leuten steckt zehn
leute an die anderen neun nicht und dann
würde man wissen wenn man zwei in einem
restaurant hatte da ist ein quell
cluster man kann dann chirurgisch in
einzelnen diese leute ansprechen in
tharandt zur testung schicken und müsst
nichts die mit der lok tank oldigs ganze
land das würde passieren wenn wir alle
luca nutzen würden aber bedeutet dann
dass aus ihrer sicht zum beispiel
restaurants hotels stadien oder konzerte
wieder möglich sind durch diese app wenn
eben mehr menschen sie installiert
hätten also kroner geht nicht weg durch
die app aber es ist im prinzip das was
viele biologen bisher auch fordern schon
seit einem halben jahr fordern nämlich
dass nun ein konzept tagebuch braucht
damit man die plaste zurückverfolgen
kann und dass das auch umfassend sein
muss man kann mit einer fußball app
nicht den restaurant usern immer muss es
schon alles in einem in einer datenlage
haben es muss voll sicher sein
dann ist datenschutz typ in thüringen
und baden württemberg beispielsweise
haben schon ihren stempel drauf gegeben
und wenn man es dann schafft dass die
kosten entlastet werden wir das ist das
was wir wollen
wir wollen die gesundheitsämter
entlasten wir wollen keine tickets
verkaufen und wir haben quasi einen
feuerlöscher mit denen sich kleine
kleine feuer löschen löschen lassen das
heißt bei einem gewissen tendenz wert
werden die business center entlastet und
sie können sich um andere sachen kümmern
und dann ist die toleranz sozusagen
höher in der man leute in locations
lassen kann und ja ich glaube es würde
eine mischung aus gehobener waren
applocker im hintergrund testing und
eine gewisse automatisierung darum und
natürlich aha wird uns schrittweise ein
normaleres leben bringen er klingt weil
wenn sie das hören und dann gleichzeitig
wissen dass die korona waren
über 60 millionen euro in der
entwicklung gekostet hat und man muss
sagen wenn man sich anschaut was sie
bislang für ergebnisse geliefert hat das
eigentlich eher desaströs ist glauben
sie dass dann so eine waren app wie hier
von smudo mitentwickelt uns helfen kann
auf dem weg zurück zur normalität
wobei ich das gar nicht gegeneinander
stellen öl und jetzt am noten verteilen
wir was besser ist oder nicht weil die
krone waren es ja auch geholfen hat und
ich sehe enormes verbesserungspotenzial
aber das was modul gerade vorgestellt
hat mit der frage der registrierung auch
der kontakt nach verfolgung ist etwas
was uns umtreiben muss und christian
lindner vorn mal gesagt wir können nicht
warten bis der inzidenz wert bei 10 ist
und da bin ich absolut einer meinung mit
ihm wir müssen ein stück weit auch
lernen mit diesem virus zu leben und
damit klar zu kommen und deswegen geht
es um impfen deswegen geht es um testen
und es geht um eine bessere kontakt
nachverfolgung und wenn wir wollen dass
kultur wieder stattfindet der sport
wieder stattfindet dass öffentliches
leben wieder stattfindet dann finde ich
stolz sein dass solche dinge jetzt
privatwirtschaftlich auch in deutschland
entwickelt werden und wir müssen uns in
der politik fragen wie können wir das
stärker nutzen wir können wir das
fördern wir können wir das einbinden in
die öffnung strategien die wert
festlegen und noch mal für mich gehört
damit zu dass die frage der
registrierung und der nachverfolgung wir
hatten das ja im sommer auch schon bei
vielen restaurants wo man sich dann ein
tragen musste das sowas jetzt auch
stärker in die strategien der politik
mit einbezogen wird
herr linder mit dem virus leben sagt
auch jetzt herr klingbeil wenn sie sich
diese waren app anschauen die dort
entwickelt wurde und die vergleichen mit
dem was wir bislang haben in deutschland
haben wir es verpasst dann solche
entwickler mehr zu unterstützen die es
vielleicht kreativer schneller und auch
günstiger hinkriegen
ich möchte das gar nicht gegeneinander
stellen das eine ist ein öffentlich
rechtliches software vorhaben das sehr
teuer und sehr langsam war und wo
sicherlich noch anlass zur weiteren
verbesserung besteht dass das eine und
das andere
ihr habt mir die app gerade hier mal
angesehen ist ein ganz tolles tool das
es ermöglicht wie wir das im sommer das
team war darauf hingewiesen in der
gastronomie gemacht haben und die wir
das in zukunft beim check in bei
veranstaltungen konzerten und anderes
tun könnten wie das besser
nutzerfreundlicher schneller ablaufen
kann
das ist ein weiterer baustein um
insbesondere kulturelles leben zu
ermöglichen
und wenn es solche möglichkeiten gibt
dann sollte der staat das aktiv begrüßen
indem wir nämlich regeln definieren
unter denen kulturelle veranstaltungen
beispielsweise stattfinden können maske
test nachverfolgung von kontakten beim
einchecken und dann kann mit einer
begrenzten teilnehmerzahl auch das
kulturelle leben wieder möglich werden
vielleicht nicht clubbing sofort aber
konzerte mit einem bestimmten abstand
theater und kino das könnte der einstieg
sagt sie sprechen das kulturelle leben
an der lindner wir möchten mit reinhold
messner sprechen darüber wie das
kulturelle leben in italien aussieht und
vor allem wie groß die sorge ist schönen
guten abend herr messner das vielleicht
im sommer gar keine deutschen touristen
und möglicherweise auch gar nicht die
kanzlerin zum urlaub kommen kann weil es
bei uns alles so langsam vorangeht mit
dem impfen und auch sonst die werte
nicht wirklich hoffnung machen wie es
die lage in italien und was ist ihr
blick momentan auf deutschland also in
italien ist die lage nicht so gut wie in
deutschland in deutschland durch die
langen moment relativ gut und das
problem ist weniger was den tourismus
angeht was in deutschland passiert
sondern das bei uns passiert also wenn
wir mit den zahlen in südtirol nicht
herunterkommen oder in norditalien
dann wird es schwierig sein
die gäste überhaupt ein zutaten und
wendig gesamteuropa voran deutschland
und der bnd mimen des teilweise herunter
kommt mit geringeren zu halten dann
können unsere hotels nicht aufsperren
das heißt ob tourismus kann gar nicht
beginnen bei mir angewiesen sind auf
internationale gäste mindestens
europäische gäste und winterzeit muss
ist schon vorbei mehr oder weniger
unsere zahlen erlauben es nicht die
hotlines aufzumachen will sheen den
skibetrieb zu möglich zu machen und
damit könnten wir sagen die wintersaison
ist vorbei die hoteliers der tourismus
generell sind am rande des überlebens
unter sommer könnte eine situation
vielleicht noch ein bisschen besser
machen oder auch vielleicht treten aber
auch für den sommer sehe ich noch keine
eindeutigen bilder oder szenen dass das
möglich wird
die kulturelle seite ist eine ganz
andere natürlich bereit steht die
kulturelle lebensäußerungen die wir alle
brauchen mehr oder weniger still
ich selber bin seit einem jahr mehr oder
weniger in pension sparen
allerdings habe ich ein buch geschrieben
und damit habe ich mich beschäftigt aber
wie konnte das was ich über jahrzehnte
gemacht habe vorträge auf trennte
filmabende nicht mehr machen und wollen
sich weltweit eintragungen hatte ich
jammere nicht darüber ich weiß entweder
wenn wir in europa in der lage alle
gemeinsam mit den zahlen herunter zu
kommen und eine kulturelle
lebensäußerung und einen tourismus
wieder zu beginnen oder wir müssen das
verschieben und deswegen gibt es nur
eins jetzt weg zu machen um dann
vielleicht im april/mai dann angemessen
sie sind da er interessanterweise genau
auf dem gleichen kurs für die kanzlerin
sprechen sie ab und somit ihr darüber
wie man vorgehen sollte sie kennen sie
ja gut eben aus ihren urlauben frau
merkel gut aber das ist ein privates
kennen
ich bin nicht in der lage so zu sagen
ratschläge von der kanzlerin anzunehmen
oder sie anzurufen das habe ich einmal
im leben getan
wir treffen uns zu einer wanderung im
jahr nach reichenberg tour und ich hoffe
dass das auch in zukunft sein wird
verhalten hoffe ich dass sie dann nach
der kanzlerschaft mehr zeit hat um in
schwung zu kommen weil ich weiß dass sie
wirklich eine begeisterte nicht
bergsteigen ist frau ist wie klamm ins
gebirge geht haben sie können sie eine
prognose abgeben müssten glauben sie die
kanzlerin kann in diesem sommer zu ihnen
kommen und bisschen bergsteigen oder
glauben sie die pandemie wird sie davon
abhalten schon mal wird es möglich sein
und die kanzlerin ist ja so abgeschirmt
dass sie nicht sorge haben muss das ist
nicht ansteigt
ich bin generell in der meinung die
bilder in israel zeigen das was wir mit
der impfung wenn es wirklich schneller
geht mit den impfstoffen von denken an
demi herunter kommen können wir können
sie nicht ausschließen die dieses
niveaus bleibt uns wir werden
wir haben lernen damit umzugehen aber
mit lockdown jahren lockt dann so
notwendig unter einem impfung werden wir
es schaffen
ich finde es eigentlich bis mai juni
mindestens so können nicht
hundertprozentig aber im grossen ganzen
herzlichen dank herr messner ich halte
die frage weiter an vor schimke gehen
sie auch davon aus dass wir im sommer
normal urlaub machen können
möglicherweise in italien das die
kanzlerin dort hinfahren kann oder wenn
wir uns jetzt die daten anschauen beim
impfen beim testen dass das in gefahr
ist und ich meine ketsch man hat ja in
der letzten woche bereits gesagt
osterferien also das gibt's schon mal
gar nicht
also ich finde wir müssen wir müssen
weil meine hoteliers hier vor ort meine
gastronom sagen mir wir schaffen es noch
bis märz ist wenn wir dann nicht öffnen
können dann sind wir weg vom markt also
insofern wir haben hohe ziele wir haben
hohe erwartungen und man sollte jetzt
alles daran tun das auch zu erreichen
also ich hoffe darauf und ich glaube
daran ja herr klingbeil wo planen sie
ihren sommerurlaub kleine
bundestagswahlkampf erstmal und da würde
ich mich auch wahnsinnig darüber freuen
wenn das wahlkampfes ruhig in präsenz
unterwegs sind
wo ich menschen ganz real treffe und
unterwegs sein kann und ich halte eine
diskussion ganz ehrlich jetzt über die
frage der der osterferien wenn jetzt die
politik wiederkommt und sagt das ist das
gar keinen fall stattfinden wir müssen
uns doch jetzt anstrengen dass wir dahin
kommen dass den menschen jetzt möglichst
schnell vieles wieder ermöglicht wird in
diesem land natürlich wir dürfen co oder
nicht verharmlosen und das habe ich
heute abend in der debatte auch nicht
erlebt es ist ein gefährliches virus die
mutation besorgt uns glaube ich alle
wenn wir die infektionszahlen jetzt auch
sehen aber politik muss man andere
signale aussenden als immer dieses zu
machen verlängern sonstwie und da gibt
es jetzt das einmal die apps die
entwickelt werden da gibt es das testen
wo wir besser werden müssen da gibt es
das impfen wo wir besser sein müssen
also lasst uns doch mal gemeinsam
anstrengen dass wir was für die menschen
im land machen und nicht jetzt schon
darüber reden was ostern oder im sommer
mit dem urlaub ist wenn wir noch gar
nicht wissen was wir bis dahin als
politik gemeinsam schaffen könnten wir
vielleicht liegt es daran dass ich ihnen
diese frage stelle das oftmals so etwas
versprochen wurde dass man sich kümmert
dass man alternative konzepte finden
will
das eröffnungs strategie geben soll dass
man unseren november gesagt hat na ja
das sind nur vier wochen in denen die
bars und restaurants geschlossen haben
also es ist ja die politik die immer
wieder ein ziel ausgegeben hat das
eingebrochen das jetzt kann man sagen na
klar das ist die pandemie
das ist alles nicht berechenbar man weiß
nicht was kommt aber dann ist es doch
auch falsch immer wieder zu sagen also
das erreichen wir auf keinen fall oder
das erreichen wir auf jeden fall in
wonsheim ich hab das ja auch
selbstkritisch gesagt ich habe es sehr
selbstkritisch gesagt an die politik
kollegen die jetzt gerade unterwegs sind
und den menschen schon mal im stammbuch
schreiben ihr könnt es sei nicht weg war
ja das ist ja was at und ich glaube die
ganze kommunikation rund um den november
lockt das muss aber kritisch dann
übrigens inklusive mir ich sage das auch
ich habe da einen fehler gemacht weil
ich geglaubt habe drei wochen jetzt
runter fahren danach wird es wieder
besser automatisch und heute müssen wir
sehen nein wir sind eigentlich immer
noch im november lockdown und wir wissen
auch nicht für die mutation sich
entwickelt wir wissen nicht wie die
infektionszahlen die nächsten wochen
sind wenn ich die letzten tage an kokain
ist es eher beängstigend aber klar ist
doch es muss eine nachvollziehbarkeit
geben ab wann passiert was klar muss
sein wir strengen uns an beim impfen und
beim testen und wenn solche neuen
entwicklung biete hektar sind
dann muss man die auch sofort einsetzen
als politik und muss das begrüßen dass
es solche privaten initiativen gibt und
das ist unsere strategie einbeziehen
aber lasst uns doch mal gucken in der
politik in der politik wohl gemerkt dass
wir bei der nächsten ministerpräsidenten
runde auch was anderes hinbekommen als
einfach noch weiter zu verschärfen und
weiter zu verlängern
herlinde der hoffnung dass bei der
nächsten ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
wie das ja auch erklingen weil fordert
nicht immer nur verschärft und
verlängert wird
das wird sich zeigen wir haben als fdp
da keinen einfluss hier sind als partei
in der liga ihre länder einfluss nehmen
zum beispiel einer versteht leider nicht
sie könnten ja sagen sie machen
bestimmte dinge nicht mit in nrw oder in
rheinland-pfalz ja dann kann man nur
regierungen platzen lassen da würde ich
die schlagzeile der bild -zeitung gerne
sehen wenn man in diesen zeiten eine
regierung platzen lässt und wie
verantwortungs könnte man sagen die
optisch zu ihren grundsätzen das würde
auch eine schlagzeile wenn sie dann
platzen lassen na ja das haben sie 2017
als wir nicht bei jamaika eingetreten
sind nicht getitelt fdp vielleicht
andere grundsätze weiß ich nicht ich war
zumindest der verzicht auf vizekanzler
amt und finanzminister wegen der
grundsätze aber spaß beiseite jetzt wir
brauchen eine bund länder runde die eine
klare perspektive aufzeigt das ziel muss
sein dinge möglich zu machen zb den
oster und den sommerurlaub ich denke an
die vielen familien wo die eltern mit
den kindern zu hause sind in der wohnung
vielleicht ohne balkon es gab keine kita
und keine schule
da liegen doch die nerven blank da ist
es jetzt eine frage der seelischen
gesundheit der menschen dass es eine
perspektive auf erholung zu ostern oder
im sommer gibt wenn man den menschen das
jetzt nimmt dann ist meine große
befürchtung dass die pandemie müdigkeit
zunimmt spricht dass die menschen sich
im geheimen nicht mehr an die regeln
halten weil sie unerträglich geworden
sind deshalb ist eine öffnung
perspektive zugleich eine neue
motivation sich auch wieder umsichtig im
alltag mit der pandemie zu beschäftigen
rücksichten zu nehmen
zum abschluss möchte ich noch jemanden
mit in die runde
der für viel diskussionsstoff in der
vergangenen woche gesorgt hat professor
wie sind langer von der universität
hamburg erwiesen dank hat in einer
studie die veröffentlicht wurde
gemeinsam mit der universität hamburg
zu 99,9 prozent aus seiner sicht
beschrieben dass corona aus einem wirren
forschungslabor stamme und eben nicht
von einem markt der stadt wo haben dann
brach sofort riesen kritik in politik
und medien los von der linkspartei
hamburg haben der vorwurf wiesen dabei
habe sich mit seinen thesen
anschlussfähig an verschwörungs
ideologen gemacht
ein ndr hieß es cooles zeug das schadet
der wissenschaft und anderes erwiesen
wie geht es in und wie sind sie mit
dieser kritik umgegangen
mir geht es gut ich denke offenheit und
wahrhaftigkeit ist die basis der
wissenschaft und wenn wir diese basis in
der wissenschaft aufgeben dann gehen wir
im prinzip den anspruch auf
wissenschaftler überhaupt zu sein und
eine vorbildfunktion auszuleben für
zukünftige generation
wir haben eine verantwortung in der
wissenschaft nicht nur für die nächsten
monate wie wir die gestaltenden dieser
pandemie sondern wir haben eine ethische
verantwortung dass wir möglichst
ausschließen dass ich solche pandemien
in regelmäßigen abständen in zukunft
wiederholen
und wenn es nun ganz deutlicher indizien
gibt die man übrigens nicht nur durch
eine gefühlte wahrscheinlichkeit jetzt
quantifizieren kann durch
wissenschaftliche methoden und ich
verweise hier auf eine jüngste noch
weitestgehend unbekannte studie eines
amerikanischen kollegen der mit
wissenschaftlichen methoden und auf der
basis der vorliegenden ergibt sinn die
wahrscheinlichkeit tatsächlich berechnet
hat und er ist zu 99 8 prozent
wahrscheinlichkeit gekommen für einen
laborunfall und nur eine 0 2 prozentige
wahrscheinlichkeit
für eine zoonose wird kritisiert herr
professor jetzt wird kritisiert dass sie
sich eben vor allem auf dieser sekundäre
quellen gestützt haben und da
zeitungsartikel zitieren auf youtube
zitieren anderes zitieren und da wird
gesagt moment mal
erstens sind sie gar nicht virologe sie
können das gar nicht wissen und sie
haben da sozusagen nur rezitiert und das
sei gar keine richtige studie was sagen
sie zu der kritik
was ist zunächst einmal haben viele
gesagt das sei ja alles bekannt dann bin
ich allerdings überrascht über die
reaktion die wir derzeit erleben wenn
das ja alles schon bekannt war und die
tausenden von zuschriften die ich jetzt
den letzten zwei tagen bekommen habe
zeigen wir ein ganz anderes bild das die
menschen eben verwirrt waren durch die
vorgaben letzten endes dies gab zum teil
auch in teil der medien dass das eben
eine zoonose gewesen sein soll
ich habe eben mit dieser studien die
frage aufgeworfen was eigentlich die
wissenschaftlichen grundlagen cent für
eine säure behauptung und ich habe nicht
gesagt dass es strikte beweise gibt
jetzt für einen laborunfall ich habe
gesagt in dieser studie und das können
sie nachlesen dass wir als
wissenschaftler ergebnisoffen
diskutieren müssen wenn es solche
strikten beweise noch nicht gibt aber
die menge und die qualität der indizien
sprechen eben im moment ganz klar eine
andere sprache nämlich die sprache eines
labor unfalls und ich möchte aus einer
fernsehdiskussion die jüngst in amerika
stattgefunden hat durch neue
enthüllungen jetzt auch der
amerikanischen beiträge zu diesen unfall
noch kommen dort es gesagt worden dass
man heutzutage eigentlich eher bei dazu
lose von einer verschwörungstheorie
sprechen müsste und gar nicht beim
laborunfall es ist tatsächlich eher so
dass wir die argumentation umkehren
müssten frau schimke wenn sie das hören
wie der professor sich ihr wehren musste
in den vergangenen tagen ist es wichtig
dass wir endlich erfahren wie krone
entstanden ist und auch welche
konsequenzen das haben muss
selbstverständlich das ist eine absolut
entscheidende frage aber vor allen
dingen ich finde es schon befremdlich
dass auch wissenschaftler die die
erkenntnisse treffen wirklich so stark
in der kritik stehen so nach dem motto
weil nicht ist was nicht sein darf ja
also in da ist die freiheit der
wissenschaft wirklich in gefahr
und insofern politische aufgabe ist es
wirklich sich solche erkenntnisse
anzunehmen und zu prüfen ob tatsächlich
was dran ist
herr klingbeil wie erleben sie die
diskussion und vor allem was muss
passieren wenn wirklich bewiesen werden
kann dass das ganze ein labor unfall war
brauchte es dann konsequenzen auch für
die chinesische regierung möglicherweise
also ich habe die debatte um die studie
verfolgt ich konnte selbst in die studie
wird die entschuldigung nicht reingucken
deswegen kann ich nur zwei
grundsätzliche bemerkungen zur
diskussion machen das eine ist dass ich
finde wir müssen in deutschland und
breiteren debatten aufstellen ich habe
schon den eindruck karte in dieser zeit
insgesamt dass wir diskussion noch sehr
stark verengt und das zweite ist finde
wir sollten einen hohen respekt vor
wissenschaft haben egal ob einem die
ergebnisse passen ob man sie richtig
findet oder nicht aber wissenschaftliche
auseinandersetzung wissenschaftliche
forschung sollten wir immer sehr ernst
nehmen sollten uns damit
auseinandersetzen und insofern sei mal
kann ich jetzt auch nicht mehr sagen als
dass man diese studien ernst nehmen muss
und ich erwarte dass die zuständigen
stellen auch in der regierung sich damit
auseinandersetzen und das prüfen und
dann noch bewerten herr lindner habe die
frage an sie braucht es konsequenzen für
die chinesische regierung müssen wir
konsequenzen ziehen in europäischen
union wo auch immer wenn rauskommt dass
es ein labor unfall war die
wissenschaftsfreiheit ist mir auch ein
ganz zentraler wert da will ich mich
lars klingbeil anschließend zu den
konkreten thesen weiß ich aber nichts
habe davon keine ahnung und deshalb kann
ich dazu auch nichts sagen
herr professor wenn sie abschließend die
politische diskussion sich hier angehört
angeschaut haben denken sie das ist
konsequenzen geben muss also zunächst
einmal ist ja die politische diskussion
um
die gefährlichkeit der geno function
forschung ja eigentlich nicht neu der
deutsche bundestag hat sich bereits 2014
mit dieser problematik beschäftigt
damals auf der basis von publikation die
höchste angreifbaren aus ethischen
gründen aus den jahren 2011 und 2012 und
der deutsche bundestag hat 2014 den
deutschen ethikrat beauftragt eben dazu
eine stellungnahme abzugeben
das heißt diese diskussion hat sowohl
auf politischer wie wissenschaftlicher
ebene vor sieben jahren schon
stattgefunden
und man muss gerade angesichts jetzt der
dramatik der kroner krise wie wir sie
derzeit erleben diese thematik wieder
auf die tagesordnung setzen und dass sie
wichtig ist das zeigt ja schon dass man
sich mit vor sieben jahren damit
beschäftigt hat und natürlich ist es
wichtig immer jetzt auch zu schauen wie
man die gegenwärtige pandemie bewältigen
kann
aber letzten endes trage ich die
verantwortung dafür wenig kenntnisse
habe letzten endes dazu beizutragen dass
wir möglichst verhindern können dass ich
sowas periodisch jetzt alle fünf bis
zehn jahre wiederholt und letzten endes
waren es wissenschaftler die 2012 die
wahrscheinlichkeit auf geschätzt haben
basierend auf dieser hoch risikoreichen
der function forschung das mit 80
prozentiger wahrscheinlichkeit innerhalb
von zehn jahren das heißt bis 2022 eine
solche weltweite pandemie ausbrechen
würde
herzlichen dank herr wiesendangen wir
nehmen ihnen appell hier zum ende mit
sie appellieren an die politik dass zum
thema zu machen das war eine wie ich
finde sehr abwechslungsreiche und in
vielen diskussionsfeld
spannende diskussionen hier heute abend
bei die richtigen fragen ich bedanke
mich bei ihnen herr professor ich
bedanke mich bei jana schimke bei
christian lindner und bei lars klingbeil
und wir nehmen mit dass sie beide wo wir
sie jetzt noch einmal zusammen sehen
sich da eigentlich sehr einig war
nämlich dass man in sachen öffnung
endlich zum thema kommen muss
und dass es da endlich beschlüsse geben
danke ihnen für die diskussion und bis
zum nächsten mal
[Musik]